I want to show you one more clip from
that interview with Maria Bartiromo
Because by the way she's basically a
trump supporter I mean I think she's
taken a lot of hits for it but in
essence is a trump supporter they talked
about whether Trump actually did drain
the swamp in the first place
like you said you would you didn't drain
the swamp I did I fired Comey I fired a
lot of people a lot of the people I had
I fired I I fired Comey very early thing
that you could look back on in 16 that
you think maybe you want to do
differently this time around well the
mistakes would be that a lot of people
for instance say you should have been
softer or this but I was under siege by
people that were very dishonest I if I
was soft I wouldn't be talking to you
right now believe me I wouldn't have
been I wouldn't have been able to finish
out one of the most successful terms as
president
to a point where it was so successful
that I'm leading by 50 points right now
you know I mean that wouldn't have
happened uh the the mistake would be
people I mean I wouldn't have put a guy
like Bill Barr and he was weak and
pathetic I wouldn't have put uh Jeff
sessions in uh there are some people
that I wouldn't have put in you know
most people were good but I had some
people uh we had uh esper I didn't like
him he was incompetent I thought we had
other people I didn't like why did you
put them in the job then because every
look every president you put somebody in
you think they're good it's an odd
Contrition a moment of Contrition almost
like a Maya culpa with him where he's he
never admits making mistakes ever but
like to basically be like I screwed up a
bunch of people that I brought in I mean
you could go through the list it's Bill
Barr Jeff sessions John Bolton
Christopher Ray esper like the list goes
on around he's turned against Kaylee
mcinany again who has he had there's
been a couple people he has not turned
on I would say junior most uh
specifically uh Rick Grinnell I mean I
guess there's a couple more but you just
have to when he says I can end the war
in 24 hours I can do I can drain the
swamp properly this time you just have
to think for yourself okay can you
actually bring in the right people to do
it
that question I leave up to you
[Music]